les plaisirs peuvent jubiler lepers et
vient de faire tomber le deuxième du
classement de nancy à domicile une joie
décuplée par le scénario du match en
première période plaisir n'arrive pas à
prendre la mesure de son adversaire et
se fait corriger 17 à 3 avec deux essais
concédés
effectivement on va en prendre 17 points
mais c'est surtout dû à nos erreurs on
les met dedans avec nos erreurs et fasse
une belle équipe comme ça c'est sûr
qu'on est sanctionné tout de suite il a
manqué un peu de maîtrise sur cette
première mi temps pour espérer faire
mieux
d'après un but et on la perd largement
et 11 remet en question dans les
vestiaires mardi le capitaine
les entraîneurs et ça nous aurait amené
un coup de un coup de jus pour finir ce
match en deuxième période les joueurs
plaisir reviennent sur la pelouse
métamorphosé arrive à inscrire trois
essais en 40 minutes de jeu
drancy a la balle de match dans les
toutes dernières secondes mais les
visiteurs n'arrivent pas à conclure
plaisir l'emporté sur le fil 24 à 23
le dernière pénalité et notamment la
dernière bon on s'en sort très bien avec
le poteau le 15 qui récupère qui fait en
avant dans l'en but
comment on pouvait pas avoir meilleur
scénario effectivement en terme de
réussite
après j'ai envie de vous dire par
rapport à tous les matches qu'on a eu
avant c'est un peu justice
qu'aujourd'hui ça tombe pour nous avec
cette victoire plaisir pointe à la 9e
place du championnat de fédérale 2 avec
7 points d'avancé sur le premier
relégable paris université club
avec cet exploit le staff plaisir on
espère désormais pouvoir terminer la
saison en milieu de tableau
[Applaudissements]